[Music]
in arch with a bang news out with I want
to die Bing Bing or Bing Bing
alright that's how I wonder there's one
of those that I'd like to go out with
though painting no guess again
I don't know then submitted by barbecue
of Koreans Oh can't be the kill a woman
commemorated her divorce by blowing up
her wedding dress with a bird like the
things from their exes you know it a
little
I would I would pay to see somebody to
launch their wedding dress into space
like I want to see it take off with two
rockets a petty skill how petty was that
Oh like I'm biased because I would love
to watch that me too I'm the energy
around the petty scale petty are you the
petty cheer song no the PETM TTY I know
I said that to you later it's so good
okay is that my theme song me walking
into any building ever what what is that
on your petty scale eye on the petty
scale I think it's like a high ten cuz
I'm like what a waste of [ __ ] time
okay really a merry [ __ ] you'll get
explosive but I'm not okay yeah if your
ex gets to see it though like you filmed
it and put it on Instagram no because I
don't
I'm over it like I'm done like I got a
butt so when me and my ex broke up I got
all his [ __ ] like Julie whatever he gave
me put in a box I gave it to a mutual
friend and I was done
cause there was like [ __ ] Jurassic
Park like welcome to meet you I saw
flying around earlier like that whole
exchange because it was like there are
two types of women
I don't kill things mosquitos yes I just
like I'm like fine like me but he's gone
now all right like oh it's a he
though he is about Kimberly this takes
place in thank us yeah Texas it was
about right yeah so her marriage of 14
years was finally finalized and so she
decided to throw a divorce party and so
she had about 40 people come over she
bought like she had $200 worth of
tannerite or about like 20 pounds of
tannerite Jesus see that's tight that's
a party like she's gonna divorce parties
with all her girlfriends like what am I
gonna just blow by with time it'll be
like a movie line I feel like yeah so
this is Kimberly and a family member it
says I'm not with stupid anymore this
one oh not that stupid anymore I'm not
saying that I imagine what they look
like in my head before but I'm not
surprised
[Laughter]
forty-year-old why would they be there's
a video oh my god I'm sorry
here we go I did that in the desert -
it's fun as [ __ ] they felt it 50 miles
out
this party didn't have to be your family
like that was your cousin he that's
hilarious
yeah that's empowering yeah they would
let her first shot too cuz she had been
practicing getting ready for this
oh she shot it just shot it and exploded
in the dark my mom when I split light
when I split my head open yes what we
did - we had one dude who made the
explosives and he puts it in like a
ziploc bag and he puts it way out there
and then we just shoot it and he
explodes
well how did you get stitches what
happened I said oh I rolled in a TV oh
yeah that was a few days like okay yeah
this just went viral because a lot of
people felt it like 15 miles out they
were like oh my god was it you guys yeah
we would just think it was an earthquake
of us here but this is in Texas I know
those I said here oh yeah for sure
yeah she was saying that the Vitt the
entire marriage was a lie so she didn't
want to just like burn it she wanted to
blow it that's awesome which makes me
think like what happened and it ain't
what I want to know I know some divorces
though it lasts forever to get out of
huh so maybe it was one of those that
was so drawn-out 14 years married to
because people can be petty like I don't
want to sign this I don't want to do
this I'm gonna do that I've heard of it
but if it sounds like it's very freeing
because like sometimes after a divorce
you know you can you get that juju out
of your life I feel like most people
after a big breakup or divorce they just
kind of sink into a depression they're
like and especially because she looks a
little older - she might be like how
will I find love again what do I do and
she looks like she's like let's [ __ ]
ride like I like that I respect that
yeah it's a good it's a very empowering
for sure I don't know who said it
horses are good I wonder what the boys
would say if they were here cuz we're
all like yeah go for her go for her I
wonder if they'd be like what kind of
gun is it
all it is easy they'd be talking about
them mm-hmm no divorces are good cuz you
know like it's just you're not happy
together you're letting go something
that you no longer need to know don't be
a [ __ ] about it
you know I've even seen couples have
divorced parties together where they end
up breaking up but they're still friends
and then they have a divorced party
together actually oddly feel like that's
kind of healthy very healthy yeah cuz my
my close role is it uh she got in a
divorce from someone that she was made
for or they were together for like 25
years or something whoa yeah and then
once the divorce started happening then
you saw the ugly side of like both
parties like he was like well I'm gonna
take this and she's like what the [ __ ]
like we got kids like what it was just
really petty [ __ ] so that was really
[ __ ] up associated when kids are
involved like dude just just go your
separate ways
it's fair and that's it you know don't
be a [ __ ] about it especially when they
use the kids yeah my parents and my
their divorced they totally just used me
as like their little pawn a [ __ ] sucks
cuz it means you care more about being
paste each other than you do about your
own kid that's so shitty I've heard of
some parents that if they are going
through a divorce they've decided we
will figure out how to end this civilly
when the children are 18 and I'm [ __ ]
with that that's pretty cool that's cool
I wonder if they have arrangements like
you're allowed to like have a side chick
or something well because if you're not
you're definitely I'll [ __ ] each
other's yeah and like if you're gonna
say like we're gonna stick this off
until the kids are ready to understand
it and you know yadda yadda yadda like I
respect that cuz sometimes like it just
doesn't work out a lot of people get
married really young and they change
like you either girl with your partner
you go apart for them oh you're in the
military you get married after your
third date you know yeah dude after
three hours yeah I hate feeling they're
already proposing some Christ man chill
damn did you ever go in those how you do
that propose mm-hmm
no you didn't huh yeah like you're
asking that question like you sound like
she knew from experience ooh that's why
mmm I can't I don't think I can date
military people it's just too much
moving around and it's too much
paperwork I'm like
I'm good are you start on nice work at
Hooters so did I really oh my god so bad
I think I have a picture somewhere I do
I have a bunch but like taxes well we
would always have military guys come in
shopping for wives like and they would
start coming in regularly UFC nights and
stuff like that and like if they landed
a Hooters girl because they they they
were just trying to wipe up get those
tax benefits and then all their other
boys were getting married so they felt
like a pressure and then like a lot of
the other girls they thought it was the
norm like I'm gonna marry a military guy
he's gonna take care of me we're gonna
have kids and it's over
that was a lot of the mentality where I
was from but yeah there was military
boys they'd be in there every night have
you ever heard of the term depend upon
amiss yeah because military dependents
because they depend on the dude so much
and then they don't do anything and they
just get big so they call him depend a
lot of misses home nor did you hear
about Billy's Mary his wife is depend
upon of us now I [ __ ] love that word
and then there's a new one that I heard
it's called a try carrot tops because
they're they're insurance called TRICARE
oh the women get the insurance too and
they call it TRICARE and tough oh my god
that's a low key really funny lots of
military friends may teach me so many
things it's great I could never be in a
relationship like that where someone's
like just taking care of me I know you
could I don't know I just need to feel
like I'm making my own money because I
don't like feeling obligated or feeling
like I owe you something or like some
like you have control over me because
you're bringing on the money
oh yeah it's it's more like um what is
it my parents are like when you're
married you have like a shared account
but then make sure you ever don't - so
I'm still making money it's just that my
like you take their money I've been like
fifty bucks a week I'm tired of making
money Nikki I'm so tired
I mean I've worked every - it sucks just
want to be taken care of Pat thanks
feminism I want to be
market that I invested it and then I
pays me then I get taken care of but my
old investments I'm learning how to
invest right now I have no idea what I'm
doing
you should read a warm Buffett
biographies in all that [ __ ]
oh okay got it oh my and abandon here
mumbling ever yours
yeah I gotta be contributing in a
relationship otherwise I feel like I
don't know I don't want I also like I've
always dated guys that like didn't how
it's a thing somebody called like that
[ __ ] out on Twitter because I was like
damn I see that picking guys that you
kind of know that you're a little too
good for it just because like like safer
yes it's safer you know like one of my
exes that I dated I bought him a car Wow
but but I just always had good jobs and
I would choose guys that were those was
safer yeah [ __ ] what kind of car you
want girl I like their car get me down
with me to David's car I want that but
yeah like I mean I I think that like and
so I'm used to contributing financially
because it makes me feel I don't really
know how else to feel that I don't know
how I plan I was on both ends so before
I was like that too I'm like I don't
need okay that makes money like all I
care about is love and and then at one
point I'm like hey let's go to ball one
he goes oh I can't afford that and then
I said and I thought to myself like is
this what I want no but like what if it
was just a guy that was like I had a job
and like he was just you guys
equally paid for things or whatever no I
ate all of that you know that
[Music]
it's very different because like when I
was younger like in an Asian chili on
your car well it's like um your dad's
always like okay get to be a good wife
you cook clean and your man pays for
everything and you like take care of the
house and the man the man cuz my dad
said she like a man man you know so
that's what I'm used to and then you
grow up and um and then I grew up in
like a world of like feminism like you
don't need a man and bla bla bla bla bla
and I'm just like well [ __ ] like you
know and at first and then it made me
feel like I was wrong oh [ __ ] I
shouldn't be like just people that by
the way I'm not judging anyone that like
the guy makes more money or whatever I'm
just saying me personally and I think it
was because of that like I grew up in a
with an Asian dad and it was like he
almost like he was like you're I'm
paying for everything so you have to do
it I like that [ __ ] cuz I'm outspoken
yeah
and so as soon as I'm as I moved out
like as much as I could pay for
everything on my own like as soon as I
could I just started cutting financial
ties in that direction and yeah and I
just never want someone else to be like
well I'm paying the bills so we're doing
exactly the thing that saves me from
that is I got a mouth it's good like I
don't shut up so it's okay oh I thought
you meant like smells good and bad like
it doesn't shut up but I suck dick too
but I've recently gone on her level like
I think maybe even this year where I'm
like oh you know what it's okay to be
taken care of like I don't have to
always show my dick - yeah he shows his
dick I'd be like well I got a dick too
much well it's more like it's cuz you've
been in a relationship long enough like
now we've been together long enough that
like if he started making more more
money and then took over I'd be like hi
[Music]